I am doing here is saying no to the
economic injustice that has been
increasing in our nation for the last
several decades my whole life basically
the promises that were made to them when
they were kids aren't being panned out
anymore and so they're like wait a
second why is this happening why are the
people getting bailed out and i'm stuck
with college loans why can't i get a job
it's actually fulfilling that I like to
do I think that's it's general
discontent from a lot of different
sources and it's coming together in one
place which is really interesting this
first guy brought to my attention with
us viral video got leaked out when a few
peaceful feminist protesters were maced
by a police officer and I decided to
come up here and help out hashtag Occupy
Wall Street you know searching that on
twitter has been the best way to get
live updates and everything you know if
you want raw gossip and raw firsthand
news what's going on that's special way
that I've going especially because the
main media sources tend to manipulate
the story according to their own
we you saw there
and then we have a live stream channel
TV channel online or did we live stream
all the
the Assembly's and ask people to ask us
questions and answer whatever they want
so they can understand what we are doing
here and why we are here I'm tweeting
out to people and tell them to retweet
I'm talking to people who live stream
I'm Austin us obvious all our Twitter
feeds all right stream feeds our
Facebook feeds and hopes that everyone
just repeats what we're saying so
basically we have the ability to amplify
our voice this hundreds of thousands
times you know people have done this
before in other countries they can tell
us what didn't work for them so if it
starts not working here we're a little
bit ahead of the game the Arab Spring
with all the brothers and sisters in in
Egypt you know they couldn't get their
word out but people brave people out
there tweeting
their messages spread out into facebook
under to Twitter gets everybody involved
it's the world involved and this
wouldn't be as big as it is right now if
it wasn't for social media this March is
specifically to raise visibility we are
trying to put as many bodies as possible
in solidarity with this movement because
everybody really belongs in this
movement almost everybody 99% of
everybody belongs here so we're trying
to just encourage people
and participate and see what